I want to hear about what it was like
shooting that action show with uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger what was that like
amazing I spent five months in Toronto
filming with Arnold shooting guns and
army crawling explosives everywhere I
was like this is insane yeah it was a
big action series coming to Netflix
sometime next year and uh yeah we were
shooting guns one day at prop guns and
uh things were exploding all around us
and he looked at me and he goes no you
know what I've been doing for four
decades yeah and the great part about
this is like you're a legit
action girl you're not like the [ __ ]
computer nerd yeah she's letting [ __ ]
off I thought I'd have a you know
slushie in the van telling people where
to run but no they had me doing all this
the the action stuff so uh move over
Marvel I'm coming I'm coming for you
baby
I mean I feel like the Marvel gig is the
ultimate gig at this point if you get a
Marvel gig you know you're going to be
in like nine moves pretty good now
you're gonna make money for
I don't think you're allowed to eat food
for nine years but luckily Netflix did
not make me get ripped they're like
let's try a different path you just to
be yourself I was like all right here we
go